you
hi everyone it's Jerry here's another
cool chess puzzle that I've been looking
forward to sharing with you
it's from 1946 I think you're really
going to like this one it's from 1946 it
was composed by Frederick Lazard that
name may ring a bell
this is not the first composition I'm
sharing with you by him in this playlist
cool chess puzzles number 14 is another
one of his and judging by the feedback
you guys left on that video many of you
took a great liking to his work to his
composition at the time of this
recording at least 570 of you gave that
one a thumbs up so let's see what you
think of this composition here where it
is white to move and as usual it is up
to you to try and find the best
continuation I suggest as I do with all
compositions you really take some time
out to try to work it out okay and now
for the solution which in my opinion is
brilliant in part because your favorite
chess engine will likely struggle to
correctly evaluate it that's only part
of it
the first move is night to e form this
is a composition that is not very deep
move wise however it does require deep
understanding this is the first key move
94 it's important to not only give check
but also prevent the King from getting
to f2 when I was trying to solve it I
tested 92 but soon realized soon
concluded that once when the King gets
to f2 there's just too many options and
we won't be able to give enough
direction to black we won't be able to
make progress here it's important to
make use of E for stopping this and
knowing that the knight cannot or should
not be captured because Bishop II 1 is
mate okay black sees this and goes to h4
and now what this is the move move to I
imagine most get stuck with
what to do here there's a couple
tempting options one is Bishop to e1 but
this is not correct why is this the case
well here's a second conclusion you
really need to come to and that is if
black is able to move their pawn to g3
open opening up a new square for the
King we're not going to be successful
we're not going to be able to get at the
black King the bishop can control h4 and
the night just by the nature of the
knight will not be able to
simultaneously control these two and
there's no fancy perpetual check we can
use to get it black Bishop II 1 does not
lead to anything after g3 g3 on move 2
is another tempting one if King h3 aha
we can give check and then checkmate but
black has a second option after g3 and
this is what you really need to see
after g3 takes there's also new square
h3 for the King to run to just like if
this pawn is no longer g4 he now has a
second option we won't be able to make
progress here either so what is the key
second move this is a tough one the star
move here is Knight g3 a move that
prevents black from playing g4 to g3
this Knight cannot be captured with the
king should not be captured because of
me he can be captured with the pawn
that's true we'll have a look at that
and what's also important to note is he
is threatening mate on f5
playing to this square threatening mate
allows this advance opening up g4 it's
important we make use of g3 and let's
look at how black could defend from here
Queen here is one way capturing the
knight is another will basically
understand or force let's just say pawn
takes Knight soon enough after Queen f8
to defend f5 now we have Bishop v1 and
we are threatening checkmate Knight f5
which would be double check black must
capture the knight in this position
otherwise Knight f5 is game over Hahn
takes Knight which is three moves in and
we're just one move away from getting to
a key final position that requires some
deep understanding final 4th move here
is Bishop f2 what's the what's the idea
behind this the idea is to get on this
diagonal this is a key position no one
other thing here after this Knight is
captured this is a an entombed King one
pawn is restricting four black pawns and
the King now black is playing without
their King Bishop f2 what's the story
behind it well there's a bunch of
different stale mating ideas White has
available one is Queen takes Bishop
stalemate no legal moves for white to
draw ok suppose Bishop is captured with
the pun it's not stalemate yet after g3
check King takes pawn King h3 are the
only legal moves and they're both
leading to stalemate
ok so we can't capture the bishop but we
could surely do some other stuff right
we have a queen and two pawns you can't
you can't make progress this is a drawn
position believe it or not suppose Queen
here all the bishop has to do is stay on
this diagonal Bishop g1 or let's just
say Bishop a7 doesn't really matter
stay on this diagonal
and you're good to go so pause there's a
check the bishop must block and black
needs to unpin the bishop on the next
move or it's going to be stalemate
suppose queen c3 we could even do fancy
stuff like Bishop here if the bishop is
captured stalemate suppose black starts
to run with one of the past pawns
after Queen c3 and Bishop b6 suppose e
starts to run we just capture it Queen
takes bishop stalemate does it matter
where these guys go as soon as they step
foot on c5 or d4 we're taking with the
bishop if the bishop has ever captured
as long as these on this dog and all
it's going to be stalemate there's only
one way to capture the bishop and it not
be stalemate and are not lead to
stalemate for as long as these on this
diagonal and that is to do something
like a check and have the bishop block
and then you take the bishop but this
position will eventually also lead to
stalemate this is maybe the only other
try because again from this position all
white has to do is stay on this diagonal
whenever there's a check here the bishop
blocks on g1 whenever a pawn moves we
take the pawn and if our bishop is
captured the black queen will be
controlling g1 and that'll be stalemate
so maybe the only try is something like
this where you take the bishop but your
King can't move entombed King g2 pun
controls for black pawns and the king
all on his own black starts to push the
king is coming over and eventually black
has to just do these moves here and in
the end we have stalemate how cool is
this puzzle I couldn't wait to share
this one with you it's just it's not
very deep move wise as mentioned but
talk about a star move Knight g3 now
basically forcing an entombed King one
pawn killing four black pawns the King
is now a prisoner and then this key move
f2 functioning on this diagonal and
there's stalemates every which way
the only other variation I didn't show
was an immediate capture of the night on
g3 on move too but in this position we
get on this diagonal right away and it
is the same storing stalemates every
which way
feel free to I encourage you I really
want to know what your feedback is on
this this is such a cool puzzle to me at
least I don't know maybe I'm
overreacting let me know what you think
this guy Frederick Lazard man he's got
some good stuff I'll be looking for more
of his puzzles to share with you soon
enough but give me some feedback let me
know what you think in the comment
section below and I hope you enjoyed it
that's all for now take care bye
you